Shure: 然后
Katrina: 烧炭
Shure: 烧炭就可以起锅
Shure: 开始一会我不知道
Shure: 咸淡我有点掌握不好
Shure: 然后一会如果淡了
Alice:直接就是巨大的面团
Jake:啊这是什么肉啊
Jake:这都牛肉
Shure: 这全是鸡肉
Shure: 然后这是鸡肉和排骨
Jake:看起来很厉害
Shure: 绝绝对香
Shure: Absolutely fragrant
Shure: 跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you
Shure: 一般不来长春都尝不到这手艺的
Shure: Generally, if you don't come to Changchun, you won't taste this skill
Shure: 今儿是偷偷漏抖都给你们了
Shure: Today, I'm secretly showing you everything
Jake:行
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 是烤的话是要在外面烤吗
Lucia: If we're grilling, do we do it outside?
Jake:对那边有个好家
Jake: Yeah, there's a good spot there
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Lucia: 这外头除了那圈墙
Lucia: Besides that wall outside
Lucia: 外头是不除了那圈墙灯没有别的灯了
Lucia: Outside, besides that circle of wall lights, there are no other lights
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:就是这5个灯
Jake: Just these 5 lights
Jake:我我可以去打光
Jake: I can set up lighting
Jake:就是你要什么灯吗
Jake: Do you need any specific lights?
Lucia: 哦没有没有
Lucia: Oh no, no
Lucia: 不是我是说如果要在外面烤的话
Lucia: I mean if we're grilling outside
Lucia: 外面其实还有点黑
Lucia: It's actually a bit dark outside
Jake:啊对没关系
Jake: Ah, it's fine
Alice:火一点起来应该好一点吧
Alice: Once we start the fire, it should be better
Jake:这氛围到位了
Jake: The atmosphere is set
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 但是只有那个就是炉子那里会亮一点
Lucia: But only the stove area will be bright
Lucia: 咱们吃饭的桌子还挺黑的啊
Lucia: The dining table is still quite dark
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 不过有那个那个影棚灯
Lucia: But there's that studio light
Alice:先找点纸盒点火吧
Alice: Let's find some cardboard to start the fire
Alice:还是有火枪啥的
Alice: Or is there a blowtorch or something
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Shure: 呃想想我下一步要做什么
Shure: 大蒜都拿着吃
Shure: Eating garlic directly.
Shure: 肉不吃蒜香味少一半呢
Shure: Without garlic, the meat loses half its flavor.
Alice:你今天晚上想吃这个吗
Alice: Do you want to eat this tonight?
Alice:那我们打开吧
Alice: Then let's open it.
Lucia: 可以吃好的
Lucia: Yeah, we can eat that.
Alice:这个蜂蜜给你
Alice: Here's some honey for you.
Lucia: 哦你不你不用这个行
Lucia: Oh, you don't need this, right?
Jake:大师我们做什么呀
Jake: Master, what are we making?
Alice:我不吃蜂蜜的
Alice: I don't eat honey.
Shure: 大师
Shure: Master.
Alice:大师你要蒜吗
Alice: Master, do you want garlic?
Shure: 不是别别
Shure: No, no.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 大师蒜拿生吃的
Shure: Master, you eat garlic raw.
Tasha: 不要
Tasha: No.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 对然后把把生菜洗了吧
Shure: Yeah, and then wash the lettuce.
Shure: 来个人把生菜洗了
Shure: Someone come wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 生吃大蒜
Lucia: Eating raw garlic.
Jake:生菜
Jake: Lettuce.
Shure: 没吃过吧
Shure: Haven't tried it, huh?
Shure: 尝尝就知道了
Shure: You'll know once you try it.
Lucia: 可以生吃而且就是跟肉在一起
Lucia: You can eat it raw, especially with meat.
Alice:我知道了但
Jake:怎么洗
Jake: How do we wash it?
Lucia: 挺好吃的
Lucia: It's pretty tasty.
Lucia: 只不过就是吃完之后会有蒜味
Lucia: But it leaves a garlic smell after.
Shure: 拿个盆装里面
Shure: Put it in a basin.
Shure: 然后把生菜洗了
Shure: Then wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 所以一般很少这样
Lucia: So, we rarely do this.
Jake:干哈干哈干哈
Jake: What's going on?
Jake:咱要干嘛
Jake: What are we doing?
Shure: 就是把生菜洗
Shure: Just wash the lettuce.
Shure: 就剩生菜没洗了啊
Shure: The only thing left is to wash the lettuce.
Jake:洗洗生菜
Jake: Wash the lettuce.
Shure: 那个土豆
Shure: The potatoes...
Alice:生菜没洗
Alice: The lettuce isn't washed.
Shure: 土豆想吃的话就削了
Shure: If you want to eat potatoes, peel them.
Shure: 然后切成片
Shure: Then slice them.
Alice:开开瓶
Alice: Open the bottle.
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 好了麻烦你们起一下这个
Katrina: Alright, could you guys move this?
Lucia: 我们找几个碗盛这个酸奶
Alice:我没有盆吗
Alice: Do we have a bowl?
Lucia: 你和我还有别小伙伴要这个吗
Jake:没有吧
Jake: I don't think so.
Alice:有人要纯酸奶吗
Alice: Does anyone want plain yogurt?
Jake:这锅怎么长这样这锅怎么长这样
Jake: Why does this pot look like this? Why does it look like this?
Alice:比较酸的
Alice: It's quite sour.
Jake:这锅为什么长成这个样子
Jake: Why does this pot look like this?
Jake:可以吃可以吃
Jake: It's edible, it's edible.
Lucia: 嗯那就3个
Lucia: Hmm, then three.
Alice:纯酸奶无糖的好
Alice: Plain yogurt without sugar is good.
Jake:嗯可以吃
Jake: Yeah, it's edible.
Tasha: 好没事
Tasha: Okay, no problem.
Lucia: 没事我可以把这个蜂蜜分享给你
Lucia: No worries, I can share this honey with you.
Alice:还有人吗还有人吗
Alice: Anyone else? Anyone else?
Lucia: 白砂糖也可以加
Lucia: You can also add white sugar.
Alice:还有人吗
Alice: Anyone else?
Alice:微微你是纯酸奶吗
Alice: Tasha, do you want plain yogurt?
Jake:我给你清掉这个东西
Jake: I'll clean this up for you.
Alice:那我们3个
Alice: Then we'll have three.
Lucia: 行那我拿两个碗
Lucia: Okay, I'll get two bowls.
Lucia: 正好我刚洗蓝莓那个碗
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake:咋的
Shure: 你看看不行了吧
Shure: Look, it's not working, right?
Lucia: 我把我把手再冲一下去
Lucia: I'll wash my hands again.
Alice:不放油也行吧
Alice: It’s okay if we don’t add oil, right?
Lucia: 我刚抓了那个生蚝袋子
Lucia: I just touched the oyster bag.
Shure: 不不行不行
Shure: No, no, it's not okay.
Shure: 得放下去
Shure: We need to add it.
Alice:你考的时候不是也要刷他吗
Alice: Don't you brush it when you bake it?
Shure: 不刷不刷
Shure: No, we don't brush it.
Jake:钢丝球呢
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: 钢丝球
Jake:是我瞎还是不在这
Lucia: 是好像是不在这
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like it's not here.
Jake:是我是是不在这OK
Jake: So it's not here, right? OK.
Jake:总觉得我看到了又没看到
Jake: I keep thinking I see it but then I don't.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Lucia: 你可能是看到了那个就是下水的那个
Lucia: Maybe you saw something else, like the drain.
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, got it.
Tasha: 没有一个地方可以
Tasha: There's no place to...
Lucia: 碗来了
Alice:拿个勺子
Alice:是不是有点抽象哈哈哈
Alice: Isn't this a bit abstract? Hahaha.
Alice:确实有点抽象
Lucia: 这个不太好弄还是拿个那个
Lucia: This is kinda tricky, let's get another one.
Lucia: 中午啊今天中午外卖没给勺
Lucia: At noon, the delivery didn't include a spoon.
Lucia: 其他的勺还有用吗
Lucia: Are there any other spoons we can use?
Lucia: 咱一会吃的时候得用勺
Lucia: We'll need spoons to eat later.
Lucia: 啊let me think
Lucia: Ah, let me think.
Lucia: 一次性餐具还有吗
Lucia: Do we have any disposable utensils left?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Lucia: 一次那个一次性餐具
Lucia: Disposable utensils.
Lucia: 因为我们好像没什么勺
Lucia: Because it seems like we don't have many spoons.
Lucia: 然后现在要舀这个
Lucia: And now we need to scoop this.
Alice:我用筷子弄的给你选一个吧
Alice: I used chopsticks, let me pick one for you.
Jake:哦一次性勺啊
Jake: Oh, disposable spoons, huh.
Lucia: 随便都行
Lucia: Anything will do.
Lucia: 但是但是
Lucia: But, but...
Lucia: 关键在于
Lucia: The key is...
Lucia: 咱们吃的时候要用勺吃
Lucia: We'll need to use spoons when we eat.
Alice:我用筷子吧
Alice: I'll use chopsticks.
Jake:咱要不买一点吧
Jake: Why don't we buy some?
Jake:买个外卖买
Jake: Order some delivery.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, hahahahaha.
Jake:不是不是哈哈哈
Jake: No, no, hahaha.
Jake:就是外卖里面有配送这些商品的
Jake: It's just that the delivery includes these items.
Alice:给你选一个这
Alice: Let me choose one for you.
Shure: 完了
Shure: Done.
Jake:这这这有的选吗
Jake: Is there even a choice?
Jake:这个左边
Jake: This one on the left.
Alice:不一样吗
Alice: Isn't it different?
Jake:对啊那选啥
Jake: Yeah, so what should we choose?
Alice:差不多你随便选
Alice: Almost the same, just pick one.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Alice:这个给你放哪
Alice: Where should I put this for you?
Lucia: 他已经要左边了我就要右边
Jake:给我放
Jake: Just put it here.
Tasha: 好了不用擦了洗不掉了
Tasha: It's done, no need to wipe anymore, it won't come off.
Tasha: 要把水沾到这个
Tasha: You need to get the water on this.
Tasha: 沾到
Tasha: Get it on.
Lucia: 这个蜂蜜是一个勺型的
Lucia: This honey is spoon-shaped.
Lucia: 所以我我可以用这个蜂蜜勺吃它
Lucia: So I can use this honey spoon to eat it.
Jake:我算洗完了吗
Jake: Am I done washing?
Tasha: 算现在要把它擦干
Tasha: Yes, now you need to dry it.
Tasha: 就是就是
Tasha: Just, just.
Tasha: 擦到看
Tasha: Wipe it to see.
Alice:无油无水状态
Alice: No oil, no water state.
Shure: 来借个剪刀把碳打开
Shure: Borrow a pair of scissors to open the charcoal.
Tasha: OK啦
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 这包纸封在这就是专门擦他的
Tasha: This pack of paper is sealed here, it's specifically for wiping it.
Jake:哦没看见多少
Jake: Oh, didn't see much.
Jake:还是瞎了点
Jake: Still a bit blind.
Tasha: 底部就不用擦了里面
Tasha: You don't need to wipe the bottom, just inside.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:爱擦就是要擦
Jake: If you like to wipe, then wipe it.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Shure: 来个帮我一起引碳的
Shure: Can someone help me light the charcoal?
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Lucia: 我马上我把这个搅好
Lucia: I'll be right there, let me finish stirring this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:不行
Jake: No way.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Jake:嘿嘿嘿对不起
Jake: Hehe, sorry.
Jake:7秒的记忆
Jake: A 7-second memory.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Jake:锃光瓦亮是不
Jake: Shiny, isn't it?
Tasha: 拿3个鸡蛋
Tasha: Grab 3 eggs.
Lucia: 我来我离得近
Lucia: I'll do it, I'm closer.
Tasha: 好那你来打吧
Tasha: Okay, you crack them.
Lucia: 我害怕我会像那天那样打吗
Lucia: I'm scared I'll mess up like last time.
Lucia: 你你来打吧要不
Lucia: Maybe you should do it instead.
Lucia: 哦因为你戴着那个手套
Lucia: Oh, because you're wearing gloves.
Lucia: 但是我怕我不会打
Lucia: But I'm afraid I can't crack it properly.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Lucia: 就那天不是打错过一次
Lucia: Didn't I mess it up last time?
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Hold on a sec.
Tasha: 来吧
Tasha: Go ahead.
Tasha: 打这个碗里
Tasha: Crack it into this bowl.
Jake:好人类早期打蛋行为
Jake: Early human egg-cracking behavior.
Tasha: 不要碰到水
Tasha: Don't let it touch the water.
Shure: 然后拿个小纸壳演传递圣火
Shure: Then use a small cardboard piece to play the torch relay.
Tasha: 打滴滴滴滴
Tasha: Crack it, crack it.
Tasha: 再滴再滴
Tasha: Keep cracking.
Lucia: 就是小心蛋黄不能破
Lucia: Be careful not to break the yolk.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, impressive.
Lucia: 第一次就成功了
Lucia: Got it right on the first try.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay!
Lucia: 要不还是你来吧
Lucia: Maybe you should do it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我我拿着一个
Lucia: Haha, I'll just hold one.
Jake:好看我的成功几个
Jake: Look at my successful attempts.
Lucia: 你那个啥
Lucia: You're, um...
Lucia: 这个要很小心的
Lucia: You have to be very careful with this.
Jake:还行吧
Jake: It's okay, right?
Jake:感觉碰到了一下问题不大
Jake: I think it's fine even if it touched a bit.
Lucia: 我解决问题的方式回避问题
Lucia: My way of solving problems is to avoid them.
Jake:我来给你跟拍
Jake: I'll follow and record you.
Tasha: 把这个还是拿到楼上冰箱冷藏
Tasha: Let's take this upstairs to the fridge.
Jake:没了
Jake: All done.
Lucia: 好的 10分钟吗
Lucia: Okay, for 10 minutes?
Tasha: OK对
Tasha: Yeah, that's right.
Tasha: 就等这边完事了
Tasha: Just wait till this is done.
Tasha: 那边就可以开始了
Tasha: Then you can start over there.
Lucia: 行好的
Lucia: Okay, got it.
Lucia: 看看这这能放下不
Lucia: See if this can fit in.
Lucia: 这好哎
Lucia: This is good.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me check.
Lucia: 算了还是放楼上吧
Lucia: Forget it, let's put it upstairs.
Alice:这可以吗
Alice:这可以也可以
Lucia: 这如果要放的话
Katrina: If we want to put it here...
Lucia: 就得把这架子重新倒腾一下
Katrina: 我看看楼上吧
Katrina: I'll check upstairs.
Katrina: 如果楼上东西不多的话应该能放下
Katrina: If there's not much stuff upstairs, it should fit.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 你是不是有酒精来着
Shure: Do you have alcohol?
Lucia: 我没有酒精
Lucia: I don't have alcohol.
Lucia: 我只有碘伏
Lucia: I only have iodine.
Lucia: 最高度数的应该是咱楼上那个百家德
Lucia: The strongest one should be the Baijade upstairs.
Lucia: 呃这也放不下
Lucia: Uh, this won't fit either.
Lucia: 呀
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这咋整
Lucia: What should we do?
Lucia: 这玩意还能喝吧
Lucia: Can you still drink this thing?
Lucia: 昨天打开的
Lucia: We opened it yesterday.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这就先放楼下吧
Lucia: Let's just put this downstairs first.
Lucia: 要不然楼上放不下了
Lucia: Otherwise, it won't fit upstairs.
Lucia: 呃靠
Lucia: Uh, damn.
Lucia: 楼下也放不下
Lucia: It won’t fit downstairs either.
Lucia: 还有什么其他需要帮忙的
Tasha: 暂时没有啦
Tasha: Not for now.
Lucia: 那我在旁边观摩
Lucia: Then I'll just watch.
Tasha: 呃好
Tasha: Uh, okay.
Lucia: 有任何需要搭把手的
Lucia: 今天是要做什么呢
Lucia: What are we doing today?
Tasha: 呃伯爵红茶
Tasha: Uh, Earl Grey tea.
Lucia: 需要先用两块纸烧一烧吗
Lucia: Do we need to burn it with two pieces of paper first?
Lucia: 还是直接用这个
Lucia: Or just use this directly?
Alice:感觉我会太我感觉会太慢了
Alice: I feel like I'm going to be too slow.
Alice:直接拿炭烧吧
Alice: Let's just use the charcoal directly.
Lucia: 碳让它燃起来
Lucia: Let the charcoal ignite.
Lucia: 是不是得花点时间
Lucia: 给先放点容易燃的东西之类的
Lucia: We should start with something that lights easily.
Alice:是他那个就是易燃物比较少
Alice: Yeah, there isn't much flammable material.
Alice:就直接用碳吧
Alice: Just use the charcoal.
Alice:反正守着煤气罐呢
Alice: Anyway, there's a gas tank here.
Alice:的通好风
Alice: Make sure there's good airflow.
Alice:别一会给大家整一氧化碳中毒了
Alice: Don't want anyone getting carbon monoxide poisoning.
Lucia: 不会的
Lucia: No, it won't happen.
Shure: 应该没事
Shure: It should be fine.
Jake:着了着了火了火了
Jake: It's lit, it's lit, the fire's up!
Shure: 着了着
Shure: It's lit.
Shure: 了着了
Shure: It's up.
Shure: 可以了走吧
Shure: It's good, let's go.
Shure: 我说那边着了已经
Shure: I said it's already burning over there.
Shure: 他也着了
Shure: It's lit too.
Jake:咋吃呢
Jake: How do we eat it?
Lucia: 嗯一般来说你得拿个勺挖着吃
Lucia: Well, usually you use a spoon to scoop it.
Lucia: 但这个装蜂蜜的勺已经被我征用了
Lucia: But I already used the honey spoon.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Jake:所以在这种情况下
Jake: So in this situation...
Alice:你可以跟我一样用筷子吃
Alice: You can use chopsticks like me.
Jake:我找找看
Jake: Let me see if I can find something.
Lucia: 对所以你就可以考虑用筷子吃
Lucia: Yeah, you can just use chopsticks.
Lucia: 这是用多少牛奶
Lucia: How much milk is this?
Lucia: 50克吗 80克
Lucia: 50 grams? 80 grams?
Tasha: 八十克
Tasha: 80 grams.
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's no way.
Jake:我再想想
Jake: Let me think again.
Lucia: 咱们那个一次性的那个勺还还在吗
Lucia: Do we still have those disposable spoons?
Jake:我觉得在感觉是我放哪去了
Jake: I think so, I feel like I put them somewhere.
Lucia: 为什么民宿里会没勺
Lucia: Why would a guesthouse have no spoons?
Lucia: 总感觉有哪里怪怪的
Lucia: Feels kinda strange.
Lucia: 应该有才对
Lucia: There should be some.
Lucia: 让我看看有没有什么别的原料
Lucia: Let me see if there are any other ingredients.
Lucia: 给您做一个
Lucia: I'll make one for you.
Lucia: 充当一下
Lucia: Acting as...
Lucia: 鉴定完毕没有
Lucia: Are you done evaluating it?
Lucia: 啊这有这有点大
Lucia: Ah, this is a bit big.
Lucia: 洗一下吧
Lucia: Let's wash it.
Lucia: 这个好没咋用过
Lucia: This one hasn't been used much.
Jake:我我已经喝我已经喝到了
Jake: I already drank it, I already drank it.
Jake:我觉得挺好的
Jake: I think it's pretty good.
Jake:就当就就硬喝就
Jake: Just drink it, just drink it.
Lucia: 筷子也不需要来一个吗
Lucia: Don't you need chopsticks too?
Jake:不用了不用了挺好的
Jake: No need, no need, it's fine.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:这啥呀这怎么做的呀
Jake: What is this? How is it made?
Jake:用鸡精调的呀
Jake: Is it seasoned with chicken essence?
Tasha: 嗯真的
Tasha: Yeah, really.
Jake:真的真的吼吼
Jake: Really, really, ho ho.
Jake:我看看你的小本本
Jake: Let me see your little notebook.
Jake:红茶包红茶包
Jake: Black tea bags, black tea bags.
Jake:哪来的买的
Jake: Where did you get them from?
Tasha: 买的
Tasha: Bought them.
Lucia: 哇这是什么味道
Lucia: Wow, what's that smell?
Katrina: 是楼下那个烧炭火的
Katrina: It's from the charcoal burner downstairs.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 我发现我衣服一直都没拿上来
Lucia: I realized I never brought my clothes up.
Lucia: 随便撂个地方吧
Lucia: Just leave it anywhere.
Lucia: 嗯这都还有水不知道大家还喝不喝
Lucia: Hmm, there's still water here, I wonder if everyone will still drink it.
Katrina: 什么东西
Katrina: What is it?
Lucia: 早晨的这个水要倒掉
Lucia: This morning's water needs to be poured out
Lucia: 这个这个应该是新杯哎
Lucia: This should be a new cup
Lucia: 这这几个呢
Lucia: What about these?
Katrina: 行啊
Katrina: Sure
Lucia: 我感觉没有
Lucia: I don't think so
Lucia: 这应该也是新杯子
Lucia: This should also be a new cup
Lucia: 嗯感觉可以
Lucia: Hmm, I think it works
Lucia: 因为我们一会如果要倒饮料就可以倒
Lucia: Because if we want to pour drinks later, we can use it
Lucia: 剩下这些是大家用过的
Lucia: These are the ones everyone has used
Lucia: 算了不关
Lucia: Never mind, forget it
Tasha: 完了又少了
Tasha: Oh no, it's less again
Jake:那咋办
Jake: Then what should we do?
Tasha: 少了没有办法
Tasha: If it's less, there's nothing we can do
Tasha: 味道浓一些
Tasha: The flavor will be stronger
Shure: 不能吧应该
Shure: Shouldn't be, right?
Jake:你上回说的你要搞
Jake: Last time you said you wanted to do
Jake:几个这种彩票款
Jake: a few of these lottery things.
Jake:你不是说想搞几个彩票款
Jake: Didn't you say you wanted to do a few lottery things?
Jake:彩票款吗
Jake: Lottery things?
Jake:看谁能吃到
Jake: See who can eat it.
Tasha: 算了呃那个打蛋器呃盆
Tasha: Never mind, uh, that egg beater, uh, the bowl.
Tasha: 对就是那个盆啊
Tasha: Yeah, that bowl.
Lucia: 呃上次用的那个
Lucia: Uh, the one we used last time.
Tasha: 就是你刚冷冻起来的那个
Tasha: The one you just froze.
Lucia: 哦get it
Lucia: Oh, got it.
Tasha: 哎还有一个呢
Tasha: Hey, there's another one.
Alice:没反应呢
Alice: No reaction yet.
Jake:压压花跳跳舞划划水
Jake: Press flowers, dance, and paddle.
Tasha: 少了一个这个
Tasha: Missing one of these.
Lucia: 少了一个
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 哎奇怪我找找看
Lucia: Hey, that's weird, I'll look for it.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯有没有可能
Lucia: Hmm, is it possible...
Jake:等快递整整理整理
Jake: Let's wait for the package and sort it out.
Lucia: 在在在在楼上呢
Lucia: It's upstairs.
Lucia: 这个不是吧
Lucia: This isn't it, right?
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No, it's not.
Lucia: 楼家要是没有我就再上楼看一下
Lucia: If it's not downstairs, I'll check upstairs again.
Lucia: 嗯啊好的
Lucia: Yeah, okay.
Jake:划划水就划完了
Jake: Just go with the flow and it's done.
Shure: 我们有特别特别高浓度的酒精吗
Shure: Do we have any really high concentration alcohol?
Jake:特别高的
Jake: Really high.
Jake:什么卧槽
Jake: What the heck?
Shure: 浓度的酒精
Shure: High concentration alcohol.
Jake:多高啊要干啥
Jake: How high? What for?
Shure: 75那种
Shure: The 75% kind.
Lucia: 助燃吧
Lucia: To help it burn?
Shure: 对就是助燃
Shure: Yeah, to help it burn.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:烧不起来是吧
Jake: So it won't burn?
Jake:喝完了还行
Jake: After drinking it, it's fine.
Lucia: 还挺干净
Lucia: It's pretty clean.
Lucia: 来我帮你
Lucia: Let me help you.
Lucia: 我我刚好帮你洗了
Lucia: I just happened to wash it for you.
Jake:哦谢谢你
Jake: Oh, thank you.
Lucia: 因为我这个也要洗
Lucia: Because I also need to wash this.
Jake:那我看看火去
Jake: Then I'll check on the fire.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 总感觉这勺子可以留一下
Lucia: Feels like this spoon can be kept.
Lucia: 要不放旁边吧
Lucia: How about putting it aside?
Tasha: 可以帮我一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me out?
Jake:那给你买一个呗
Jake: Then I'll buy you one.
Lucia: 嗯你说
Lucia: Uh, go ahead.
Tasha: 加75克糖
Tasha: Add 75 grams of sugar.
Shure: 或者买药那块
Shure: Or buy it from the pharmacy.
Shure: 最快的应该
Shure: That should be the fastest.
Tasha: and 0.5的茶
Tasha: And 0.5 of tea.
Tasha: 3个蛋黄
Tasha: 3 egg yolks.
Lucia: 这个碗里没有油就是好洗
Lucia: This bowl is easy to wash without oil.
Tasha: 75克柠檬
Tasha: 75 grams of lemon.
Lucia: 15克糖
Lucia: 15 grams of sugar.
Jake:看30分钟
Jake: Check 30 minutes.
Jake:是他先到还是你先着是吧
Jake: See if it arrives first or you start first, right?
Lucia: 是按一下清零
Lucia: 放上去按一下清零是吗
Lucia: i hear that you like the bad girls hurting with the shoes 15
Lucia: I hear that you like the bad girls hurting with the shoes 15.
Lucia: 75
Lucia: 嗯这块好大
Lucia: Hmm, this piece is so big.
Tasha: 好了吗哦
Tasha: Is it done? Oh.
Lucia: 还没好
Lucia: Not yet.
Lucia: 是75克吗
Lucia: Is it 75 grams?
Tasha: 先到20 呃先到21.7
Tasha: First to 20, uh, first to 21.7.
Lucia: 现在21.7克
Lucia: Now it's 21.7 grams.
Tasha: 呃因为我要先加
Tasha: Uh, because I need to add first.
Lucia: 再来一点
Lucia: A bit more.
Tasha: 低呃算了
Tasha: Low, uh, never mind.
Tasha: 快到吧
Tasha: Hurry up.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Done.
Tasha: 这是不是有点太小了
Tasha: Isn't this a bit too small?
Lucia: 有可能我们要不倒多少
Lucia: Maybe we should pour some more?
Tasha: 分两次
Tasha: Do it in two times.
Lucia: 然后取对取下来再那个什么
Lucia: Then take it out and do it again?
Lucia: 你是刚好要加两次吗
Lucia: You need to add twice, right?
Tasha: 我要加三次
Tasha: I need to add three times.
Tasha: 那你倒35克先
Tasha: So you pour 35 grams first.
Tasha: 然后剩下的你再倒35
Tasha: Then pour the remaining 35.
Lucia: 34.8可以吗
Lucia: Is 34.8 okay?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: It's fine.
Lucia: 要在这里面
Lucia: Should it be in here?
Lucia: 在在家吗
Lucia: At home?
Jake:其实还行吧
Jake: Actually, it's fine.
Jake:他说8:50就到了
Jake: He said he'll be here by 8:50.
Lucia: 刚才是35
Lucia: It was 35 earlier.
Tasha: 三十五
Tasha: Thirty-five.
Lucia: 那这个这个是要到多少
Lucia: Then how much should this one be?
Tasha: 四十啊
Tasha: Forty.
Lucia: 直接到40啊
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: 40克好你来
Tasha: 好你来
Lucia: 26.8829.9
Jake:凑30是吗
Tasha: 40啊
Lucia: 40差不多
Tasha: 好差不多来
Lucia: 外面那点不管他
Jake:哦
Jake:好
Jake:这么多数字我用几
Tasha: 拉到最大就行哎呦
Alice:哈哈没事
Jake:哈哈哈你不是说拉到最大就行
Jake: Hahaha, didn't you say to pull it to the max?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你猜
Lucia: Hahaha, guess what?
Tasha: 好好来吧
Tasha: Alright, let's do it.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: Me.
Lucia: 你猜我那天裤子上奶油是怎么奔上的
Lucia: Guess how the cream got on my pants that day?
Tasha: 来吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Shure: 就是阳阁楼上
Shure: It's just the attic.
Shure: 你把那个窗户关上
Shure: Close that window.
Shure: 这算找下来吗
Shure: Does this count as finding it?
Shure: 这没算找下来
Shure: This doesn't count.
Jake:是这么回事吧
Jake: Is that how it is?
Tasha: 停了加最后一次糖吧
Tasha: Stop, and add the last bit of sugar.
Lucia: 我不知道要问威威
Lucia: I don't know, you need to ask Tasha.
Tasha: 加最后一次糖
Tasha: Add the last bit of sugar.
Lucia: 谁
Lucia: Who?
Tasha: 停停加最后一次糖
Tasha: Stop, stop, and add the last bit of sugar.
Lucia: 我把这掉出来这糖稍微清一下
Lucia: Let me clean up this sugar that fell out a bit.
Lucia: 这个应该我有点不敢靠近你哈哈哈
Lucia: I don't really dare to get close to you, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这个应该没用了
Lucia: This is probably useless now.
Lucia: 酸奶都吃完了
Lucia: The yogurt is all gone.
Jake:他为什么能打起来啊
Jake: Why did it catch fire?
Tasha: 他他把空气给抽出去了
Tasha: He sucked out all the air.
Tasha: 然后他就会膨胀
Tasha: Then it'll expand.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Alice:不是没有这个可能
Alice: It's not impossible.
Tasha: 好停一下
Tasha: Okay, stop for a moment.
Tasha: 嗯你看停到什么样的程度
Tasha: Hmm, look at what level you stopped at.
Tasha: 就你你这样子拉他他就立起来了就行
Tasha: If you pull it like this, it should stand up.
Tasha: 东西有点太多了哦哎
Tasha: There's too much stuff, oh.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 不要再打了
Tasha: Don't hit it anymore.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Tasha: 对把它拔下来洗了就行
Tasha: Yeah, just pull it off and wash it.
Jake:对好的
Jake: Yes, okay.
Jake:这个是挺
Jake: This is pretty...
Jake:什么什么叫打过啊
Jake: What do you mean by "hit over"?
Jake:这还能打过呢
Jake: This can still be hit?
Jake:太硬了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake:哦没关系
Jake: Oh, never mind.
Tasha: 加85克这个这个嗯
Tasha: Add 85 grams of this, um.
Jake:排练一下
Jake: Rehearse a bit.
Jake:最后一天我好好打
Jake: I'll do it well on the last day.
Lucia: 85克呃这个这是什么呀
Lucia: 85 grams, uh, what is this?
Tasha: 你可以先倒40克
Tasha: You can pour 40 grams first.
Lucia: 低筋粉好的
Lucia: Low-gluten flour, okay.
Tasha: 然后再加45克
Tasha: Then add another 45 grams.
Tasha: 但感觉这个是不是有点小
Tasha: But doesn't this feel a bit small?
Lucia: 这个碗是吗
Lucia: This bowl, right?
Tasha: 容器有点太小了
Tasha: The container is a bit too small.
Lucia: 哈哈哈试试看先 4045
Lucia: Haha, let's try it first, 40 and 45.
Lucia: 可能有点
Lucia: Maybe a bit...
Tasha: 我感觉这个
Tasha: I feel this...
Lucia: 这个这
Lucia: This, this...
Tasha: 这个小碗倒30克可能就差不多
Tasha: This small bowl might be just right for 30 grams.
Tasha: 好那就那就30克吧
Tasha: Okay, then let's go with 30 grams.
Tasha: 那加3次要加85克
Tasha: So, we need 85 grams in total, added in three times.
Lucia: 行稍等二九点啊
Lucia: Okay, hold on, almost there.
Lucia: 再来一点
Lucia: Add a bit more.
Lucia: 耶刚好
Lucia: Yay, just right.
Lucia: 第二回放多少 20还是25
Lucia: How much for the second time? 20 or 25?
Jake:为了不断为了不止于羞辱
Jake: To avoid, to avoid humiliation.
Tasha: 都可以只要最后一共是85就行
Tasha: It doesn't matter, as long as it totals 85 grams in the end.
Lucia: 一共85 刚才30啊
Lucia: A total of 85, earlier was 30, right?
Jake:能放油吗
Jake: Can we add oil?
Lucia: 那还差50
Lucia: Then we still need 50.
Jake:你这个火
Jake: This heat...
Lucia: 那就那就2525行吗
Lucia: Then let's go with 25 and 25, okay?
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: We can.
Shure: 因为正常烤时要放酱油的因为我忘记了
Shure: 对然后就是靠酱油带带
Shure: Yeah, then just rely on the soy sauce to give it flavor.
Jake:那就那还能
Jake: Then, can we still...
Jake:还能救吗
Jake: Can it still be saved?
Shure: 不是一个是带色
Shure: Well, one is for color...
Shure: 再一个就是咸味嘛
Shure: And then there's the salty taste.
Alice:咸味嘛
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 那就补补点这个呗
Shure: Let's just add a bit more of this.
Jake:补点吧可以
Jake: Sure, add a bit more.
Lucia: 24.9
Jake:来上酱油
Jake: Let's add some soy sauce.
Shure: 酱油没有
Shure: We don't have soy sauce.
Shure: 咱们我以为不用
Shure: I thought we didn't need it.
Shure: 所以我就没买你知道吗
Shure: So I didn't buy any, you know?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那咋办呢放点盐
Jake: What should we do then? Add some salt?
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's fine, it's fine.
Shure: 就是缺缺这个
Shure: We're just missing this.
Shure: 就补了点烧烤料就差不多
Shure: Just add some barbecue seasoning, that should do.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Jake:低配版问题不大
Jake: The low-budget version isn't too bad.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jake:为最后一天准备是吧
Jake: Preparing for the last day, right?
Shure: 80%还原了已经
Shure: We've already restored 80%.
Shure: 货不货
Shure: Is it okay?
Lucia: 24.8行吗差的不OK
Lucia: 24.8, is that alright? It's not okay.
Shure: 还有那个
Shure: And then...
Shure: OK
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 哇这个低筋粉用的还蛮快的咦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, we're using up the low-gluten flour really fast, haha.
Shure: 那个一会记得也呼了一下
Shure: Remember to call for it later.
Shure: 我再去看外面看看火
Shure: I'll go check the fire outside.
Shure: 好火彻底灭了
Shure: Alright, the fire's completely out.
Shure: 哦你问问管家
Shure: Oh, ask the butler.
Jake:一点火星都不剩
Jake: Not a single spark left.
Shure: 管家能不能帮忙送个酒精啥的
Shure: Ask the butler if they can help with some alcohol.
Shure: 应该有你快问一下酒精啥的
Shure: They should have some, quickly ask for some alcohol.
Shure: 反正最后一天也得用
Shure: Anyway, we need to use it on the last day.
Shure: 你问问管家有没有酒精
Shure: Ask the butler if they have any alcohol.
Shure: 能吃上吧
Shure: Can we eat yet?
Jake:蛋糕能吃上吧
Tasha: 蛋糕不能吃上
Lucia: 烤的时间比较久是吗
Lucia: Did it take a long time to bake?
Tasha: 对呀
Lucia: 哇这个这个
Lucia: Wow, this...
Lucia: 好像我爸每次炒的牛肉
Lucia: It looks like the beef my dad fries every time.
Lucia: 他就会拌成这样
Lucia: He always mixes it like this.
Lucia: 非常非常像
Lucia: It looks exactly like it.
Tasha: 茶包哎
Tasha: Tea bag, hey.
Tasha: 我刚拿了吗
Tasha: Did I just take it?
Lucia: 饿了哈哈哈饿了
Lucia: Hungry, hahaha, I'm hungry.
Alice:好想下手抓一抓
Alice: Really want to grab it.
Tasha: 然后加哦
Tasha: Then add it, oh.
Tasha: 植物油植物油
Tasha: Vegetable oil, vegetable oil.
Tasha: 哎哎这呢
Tasha: Hey, hey, here it is.
Jake:这叫伯爵奶茶是吗
Jake: Is this called Earl Grey milk tea?
Tasha: 油呢油呢哎油呢
Tasha: Where's the oil, where's the oil, hey, where's the oil?
Lucia: 呃会不会在楼上应该不会
Tasha: 哎这谁拿到这的
Tasha: Hey, who took this here?
Alice:每件浅色衣服都逃不过
Alice: Every light-colored piece of clothing can’t escape.
Shure: 拿点
Shure: Take some.
Tasha: 好能把搅一下吗
Tasha: Okay, can you stir it?
Tasha: 就是拿筷子搅一下
Tasha: Just stir it with chopsticks.
Shure: 厨房湿巾在哪
Shure: Where are the kitchen wipes?
Shure: 楼上吗
Shure: Upstairs?
Jake:厨房湿巾
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia: 等一下我那个
Lucia: Wait a minute, my um...
Lucia: 呃餐巾纸我拿一张
Lucia: Uh, napkin, I'll take one.
Lucia: 要不然筷子板上来又没事
Lucia: Otherwise, the chopsticks board comes up again, it's fine.
Lucia: 等一下还没搅完
Lucia: Wait, I haven't finished stirring.
Lucia: 搞完再弄一下
Lucia: Finish it and then do it again.
Lucia: 是要大概搅到啥程度呀
Lucia: How much do you need to stir it?
Tasha: 融合就行
Tasha: Just until it's blended.
Tasha: 没关系这里面还会再融的
Tasha: It's okay, it will blend more inside.
Lucia: 啊这俩要要要融合可能要
Lucia: Ah, to blend these two might take...
Shure: 把那个一会烤架给擦一下
Shure: Wipe the grill later.
Jake:这好融啊
Jake: It's blending well.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Done.
Lucia: 哈哈先把牛顿
Lucia: Haha, first Newton...
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么融化
Jake: Hahaha, how does this melt?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 但是这个这个原理是牛顿发现的
Lucia: But this principle was discovered by Newton.
Jake:不管他不管不管
Jake: Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
Lucia: 不管他反正对
Lucia: Doesn't matter, anyway, yeah.
Jake:反正物理有物理的问题
Jake: There are physical problems in physics.
Tasha: 物理学不存在
Jake:对对对
Jake: Right, right, right.
Lucia: 跟物理学有关的问题都归到牛顿头上
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 你要来搅拌吗有没有人
Lucia: 我来
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Lucia: 怎么搅
Tasha: 就搅就行了
Alice:擦完之后是不是还得洗
Alice: Do we need to wash after wiping?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Alice:这上面可是洗洁精之类的那种东西
Alice: But there's detergent and stuff on it
Tasha: 因为会打过
Tasha: Because it will be used
Alice:你却也能吃肚子里
Alice: You can still eat it
Tasha: 应该没有问题了
Tasha: It should be fine now
Jake:那为什么不能用他的那个一
Jake: Then why can't we use his one
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Tasha: 你真的很聪明要不你来
Tasha: 这是切蛋糕
Tasha: This is for cutting the cake
Alice:大的小的
Alice: Big ones or small ones?
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Amazing
Jake:这是切蛋糕的
Jake: This is for cutting the cake
Lucia: 呃对那天微微解释一下他怎么用的
Lucia: Uh, right, Tasha explained how to use it the other day
Lucia: 但是其实我也没搞明白
Lucia: But I still didn't get it
Lucia: 反正总之就是这样用的
Lucia: Anyway, that's how you use it
Jake:什么时候切
Jake: When do we cut it?
Tasha: 等会就切
Tasha: We'll cut it later
Tasha: 你要切吗
Tasha: Do you want to cut it?
Jake:我要切
Jake: I want to cut it
Tasha: 好你切
Tasha: Okay, you cut it
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright
Jake:我想象不出来
Jake: I can't imagine
Jake:一点都想象不出来
Jake: I can't imagine at all
Tasha: 你能帮我扶一下
Tasha: Can you help me hold this?
Tasha: 从这开始
Tasha: Start from here
Lucia: 这个大概搅成什么样呀
Lucia: What should this be stirred to?
Tasha: 就这样就行了
Tasha: Just like this is fine
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Okay
Tasha: 只不过我这边还在压模具
Tasha: But I'm still pressing the mold over here
Lucia: 嗯那我趁你压的时候接着搅搅
Lucia: Then I'll keep stirring while you press
Tasha: 压的不好看
Tasha: It's not pressed nicely
Tasha: 不过没关系
Tasha: But it's okay.
Tasha: 我不想认真叠它了就这样
Tasha: I don't want to fold it seriously, just like this.
Alice:我的边边呢
Alice: Where's my edge?
Tasha: 什么你来好了呀
Tasha: Whatever, you do it then.
Alice:like that
Alice: Like that.
Tasha: 要越高越好
Tasha: The higher the better.
Tasha: 因为这样子可以减少它的气泡
Tasha: Because this way it reduces bubbles.
Tasha: 据说是这样子
Tasha: That's what they say.
Tasha: 不知道我做了几个人的量
Jake:这就整完了
Jake: It's all done.
Jake:就剩烤了
Jake: Just need to bake it.
Jake:这是预热过的
Jake: It's preheated.
Jake:烤40分钟
Jake: Bake for 40 minutes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:就等着就行了嗯
Jake: Just wait, that's all, yeah.
Tasha: 然后再打发个奶油就行
Tasha: Then whip some cream.
Tasha: 但是奶油打发等它快烤出来再打就行
Tasha: But whip the cream when it's almost done baking.
Shure: 咱们最后一天是周一还是周日来着
Shure: Is our last day Monday or Sunday?
Jake:周日哎
Jake: Sunday, yeah.
Jake:周周一周日搞完活动周一
Jake: Sunday, finish the event, and Monday.
Jake:呃划划水
Jake: Uh, wrap up and dismantle the place.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:复个盘拆屋子
Jake: Clean up and dismantle the place.
Tasha: 我们结束了
Tasha: We're done.
Jake:把屋子拆了
Jake: Tear down the place.
Tasha: 这个还要小
Tasha: This needs to be smaller.
Tasha: 没事了
Tasha: It's fine.
Tasha: 这个洗了等会打奶油用
Tasha: Wash this and then we'll use it to whip the cream later.
Lucia: 打奶
Lucia: Whip cream.
Alice:打奶油
Alice: Whip the cream.
Alice:去上个厕所
Alice: I'm going to the bathroom.
Alice:先放一下
Alice: Hold this for a moment.
Jake:我们没有汽油但是可以
Jake: We don't have gasoline, but...
Shure: 哈哈哈他有两块
Shure: Haha, he has two pieces.
Shure: 着了汽油你可以倒回家去
Shure: Once the gasoline ignites, you can go home.
Jake:但是汽油你可以到换家借
Jake: But you can borrow gasoline from the neighbors.
Shure: 哈哈我操
Shure: Haha, oh crap!
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha: 所以是烤不开是吗
Tasha: So it won't cook?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha: 点不着是吗
Tasha: It won't light, right?
Shure: 马上着了
Shure: It'll light soon.
Shure: 酒精马上到了
Shure: The alcohol is almost here.
Jake:哈哈还特地买了酒精
Jake: Haha, you even bought alcohol.
Shure: 你们可以出来
Shure: You guys can come out.
Shure: 就是布置布置这桌子
Shure: Just need to set up this table.
Shure: 马上就能吃了
Shure: We can eat soon.
Shure: 先把饼给你们画圆了
Shure: Let me draw the circles on the pancakes for you.
Shure: 然后可以布置布置桌子了
Shure: Then we can set up the table.
Shure: 准备准备吃了
Shure: Get ready to eat.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:至少就是那个几块钱
Jake: At least it's just a few bucks.
Katrina: 去外面是吗
Katrina: Outside, right?
Jake:半毛半毛新币
Jake: Half a Singapore dollar.
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Jake:5毛新币
Jake: 50 cents.
Lucia: 不记得了
Lucia: I don't remember.
Jake:是
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 但是你可以试试看
Lucia: But you can give it a try.
Jake:简单的快乐
Jake: Simple pleasures.
Lucia: 嗯不好意思
Tasha: 它切出来就是最底层的
Tasha: 你想要那一层就往哪一层切就行了
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 然后你把蛋糕放在这
Tasha: And then you place the cake here.
Tasha: 然后这样子过去
Tasha: Then move it like this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 好等会你来展示
Tasha: Okay, you'll demonstrate later.
Jake:好的交给我吧
Jake: Sure, leave it to me.
Jake:我先切一个土豆试一试
Jake: Let me try cutting a potato first.
Tasha: 如果说你们想要切三层对吧
Tasha: If you want to cut three layers, right?
Tasha: 那那你可能就要在第一层
Tasha: Then you might need to do the first layer.
Tasha: 第三层和最上面一层
Tasha: Third layer, and the top layer.
Jake:嗯没问题
Jake: No problem.
Tasha: 这样子就可以切出来
Tasha: That way you can cut it out.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:我先试试
Jake: Let me try first.
Tasha: 不是还要加芒果吗
Tasha: Don't forget to add mangoes.
Tasha: 然后我们可以一层芒果夹心
Tasha: Then we can have a mango layer.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Tasha: 一层奶油夹心
Tasha: And a cream layer.
Katrina: 啊好好吃
Katrina: Ah, so delicious.
Tasha: 然后一层草莓夹心等等
Tasha: Then a strawberry layer, and so on.
Jake:然后一层
Jake: And then a layer...
Jake:哦好好好
Jake: Oh, okay, okay.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:怎么做啊
Jake: How do we do it?
Jake:那就切草莓
Jake: Let's cut the strawberries.
Jake:切芒果的是吧
Jake: And cut the mangoes, right?
Tasha: 你不是说尽量把芒果消灭掉吗
Tasha: Didn't you say to use up all the mangoes?
Jake:就是就是把它切成碎
Jake: Yeah, just chop them up into pieces.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 豆和巧克力豆夹心夹层
Tasha: Beans and chocolate chip filling.
Tasha: 所以大家要吃什么夹层
Tasha: So, what filling do you all want?
Tasha: 就夹什么夹层就行了
Tasha: Just use whatever filling you like.
Katrina: 天好幸福
Katrina: Oh, this is so delightful.
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow.
Katrina: 芒果的芒
Katrina: Mango pieces.
Alice:芒果
Alice: Mango.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:芒果在这
Jake: The mango is here.
Jake:我要怎么准备它
Jake: How should I prepare it?
Tasha: 把皮削了
Tasha: Peel it.
Tasha: 然后你如果想吃大块的你就不切
Tasha: And if you want big chunks, don't cut it.
Tasha: 就直接一片一片的加进去
Tasha: Just add it in slices.
Jake:好我先去拿个酒精
Jake: Okay, I'll get some alcohol first.
Tasha: 如果你想吃芒果丁你就全部都切成丁
Tasha: If you want mango cubes, just chop it all into cubes.
Shure: 我还没叫呢
Shure: I haven't called yet.
Jake:好嘞好好好没问题
Jake: Alright, alright, no problem.
Tasha: 敷衍
Tasha: Half-hearted.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Tasha: 嗯我要吃肉哈哈
Tasha: Hmm, I want to eat meat, haha.
Lucia: 那等一下
Lucia: Wait a minute.
Lucia: 他们应该很快就可以考了
Lucia: They should be able to bake it soon.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 一个蛋糕会不会太少了要不要在烤店
Tasha: Will one cake be enough? Should we bake more?
Tasha: 纸杯的反正也很简单
Tasha: The paper cups are really simple anyway.
Shure: 我就多放了点那个烧烤料
Shure: I just added a bit more BBQ seasoning.
Lucia: 都可以你决定
Lucia: It's up to you, you decide.
Tasha: 所以那天的量是10个的量
Tasha: So that day’s amount was for 10 servings.
Lucia: 对我们做出来了十个
Lucia: 如果今天已经有一个大一点的蛋糕的话
Tasha: 所以还是考10个就行了
Tasha: So just bake 10, it's fine.
Jake:哈哈哈来吧
Jake: Hahaha, come on.
Tasha: 超级简单这个
Tasha: This is super easy.
Lucia: 也可以如果如果
Lucia: You could if you want.
Lucia: 今天晚上吃不
Lucia: Are we eating tonight?
Lucia: 完的话
Lucia: If not,
Lucia: 冷藏到明天早上当早饭也可以是吗
Lucia: We can refrigerate it and have it for breakfast tomorrow, right?
Tasha: 可以吧
Tasha: I think that's okay.
Lucia: 好呀
Lucia: Cool.
Lucia: 不会那个什么
Lucia: It won’t,
Tasha: 嗯应该可以吧
Tasha: Hmm, it should be fine.
Tasha: 那只需要把这个擦干就行了
Tasha: We just need to wipe this dry.
Tasha: 然后我们嗯
Tasha: And then we, um,
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 完全看不见他的状态
Tasha: We can't see his status at all.
Tasha: 我干错了我挑战一下他
Tasha: I made a mistake, I’ll challenge him.
Tasha: 他已经
Tasha: He's already...
Lucia: 哦这个太挨着上面了是吗
Lucia: Oh, is this too close to the top?
Tasha: 对所以哎呀完了有一张纸掉上去了
Tasha: Yes, so... oh no, a piece of paper fell on it.
Lucia: 拿筷子剪出来行吗
Lucia: Can we use chopsticks to cut it out?
Tasha: 嗯可以我就感觉他太靠上了
Tasha: Hmm, okay. I just feel it's too close to the top.
Lucia: 哎刚刚用的那根筷子上哪去
Lucia: Hey, where did the chopsticks we just used go?
Tasha: 所以想要挑
Tasha: So I wanted to pick it.
Lucia: 是不是已经被洗了
Lucia: Have they already been washed?
Lucia: 擦一下
Lucia: Wipe it.
Lucia: 要不要把底下这层撤了
Lucia: Should we remove the bottom layer?
Lucia: 然后光放一层
Lucia: Then just leave one layer.
Tasha: 对我刚刚想的也是把它放在
Tasha: Yeah, I was thinking about putting it...
Tasha: 蛋糕雏形
Tasha: The cake's shape.
Lucia: 拆一下
Lucia: Take it apart.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Alice:酒精送到了
Alice: The alcohol has arrived.
Tasha: 擦干就行
Tasha: Just dry it.
Tasha: 继续准备一下原材料
Tasha: Let's continue preparing the raw materials.
Katrina: 继续往前走
Katrina: Keep moving forward.
Tasha: 我去我军手套只有最后一双了不戴了
Tasha: Oh no, my military gloves are down to the last pair, not wearing them.
Alice:来煽风点火了
Alice: Here to fan the flames.
Lucia: 好像可以了
Lucia: Seems like it's done.
Jake:我来切哦
Jake: I'll cut it, okay?
Alice:圣火来了
Alice: The sacred fire is here.
Shure: 慢慢慢慢来慢慢来
Shure: Slowly, slowly, take it easy.
Shure: 再慢点再慢点再慢点OK
Shure: Slower, slower, okay.
Katrina: 你最擅长
Katrina: You're the best at this.
Jake:哎是为什么要打奶油是吗
Jake: Oh, why do we need to whip cream?
Katrina: 哎是来
Katrina: Oh, it's here.
Lucia: 哎这个是还没洗是吧
Lucia: Hey, this isn't washed, right?
Lucia: 这个不用洗不用洗
Lucia: This doesn't need washing.
Tasha: 这个不用洗因为他还是放蛋黄
Tasha: You don't need to wash this because it still has the egg yolk.
Lucia: 哦行
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Shure: 给他
Shure: Give it to him.
Tasha: 让你打3个蛋你怎
Tasha: I told you to crack three eggs, why...
Jake:这样好不行啊
Jake: Doing it this way isn't good.
Lucia: 补充点能量才能打得好
Lucia: You need to recharge a bit to do it well.
Jake:对对对打蛋得费劲呢
Jake: Yeah, yeah, cracking eggs is tiring.
Alice:喷点酒精
Alice: Spray some alcohol.
Jake:打了打了
Jake: Cracked it, cracked it.
Tasha: 这呢这呢
Tasha: Here, here it is.
Tasha: 无菌手套不够了不戴了我洗干净
Tasha: There aren't enough sterile gloves, so I won't wear them. I'll just wash my hands thoroughly.
Jake:好
Tasha: 好好好好好
Tasha: Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Lucia: 他盖着盖子
Lucia: He's covering it with a lid.
Jake:嗯好谢谢
Jake: Uh-huh, thanks.
Lucia: 哇好厉害啊
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 打蛋是一门学问你学不来
Tasha: Cracking eggs is an art you can't master.
Lucia: 对我学不来哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, I can't learn it, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 我学不来
Tasha: I can't learn it.
Tasha: 我替他在说这句话
Tasha: I'm saying this for him.
Tasha: 哎好他们不愿意分开
Tasha: 好愿意了
Tasha: the next
Tasha: The next.
Jake:哎我觉得
Jake: Hey, I think...
Lucia: 再再来一个是吧
Lucia: Let's do another one, right?
Jake:哈哈哈我觉得还有两个赞嘛
Jake: Hahaha, I think there are two more likes.
Lucia: 我来
Lucia: I'll do it.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 专注气氛组一万年
Lucia: Focus on the atmosphere team for ten thousand years.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 你这个会磕太厉害了
Lucia: You're hitting it too hard.
Lucia: 小心哇这都没烂哈哈
Jake:没问题没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 天选打单人
Lucia: The chosen one plays solo.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:是这是逐步探索边界
Jake: Yes, this is gradually exploring the boundaries.
Lucia: 他刚才超级强的磕了一下竟然弄没了
Lucia: He hit it so hard just now, it's gone.
Tasha: 这个这个这个放到那个冷藏yes
Tasha: This, this, put it in the fridge, yes.
Lucia: 对OK
Lucia: Right, okay.
Lucia: 看一眼那可能还是得放到楼上去
Lucia: Take a look, maybe we should put it upstairs.
Tasha: 你可以把这个没事你去吧
Tasha: You can take this, it's fine, go ahead.
Lucia: 这个这个放在哪
Lucia: Where should I put this?
Lucia: 这已经擦好了
Lucia: This is already wiped clean.
Tasha: 呃干的就放在这就行我觉得
Tasha: Uh, just put the dry one here, I think.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Got it.
Jake:哎真好看
Jake: Wow, it looks great.
Tasha: 没问题没问题
Tasha: 他怎么洗着洗着碗跑了呢
Tasha: Why did he run off while washing the dishes?
Lucia: 呃那是要洗啥呀我来
Lucia: Uh, what needs to be washed? I'll do it.
Tasha: 这个洗干擦干就行
Tasha: Just wash and dry this, that's it.
Tasha: 哇那我们可以开始吃了
Tasha: Wow, then we can start eating.
Lucia: 这不能用吧
Lucia: This can't be used, right?
Tasha: 哎他回来了哈哈
Tasha: Hey, he's back! Haha
Tasha: 交给您
Tasha: I'll leave it to you.
Tasha: 您来
Tasha: You do it.
Tasha: 您愿意
Tasha: If you want to.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Tasha: 你来把它搅拌
Tasha: You stir it.
Tasha: 给你你从此学会烘焙
Tasha: Here, now you'll learn baking.
Jake:好的
Jake:我拿什么搅
Tasha: 筷子帮您准备好了
Tasha: The chopsticks are ready for you.
Jake:好谢谢你
Tasha: 完了就这样吧
Tasha: Okay, that's it.
Jake:啥意思
Tasha: 开始把它充分搅拌
Tasha: Start mixing it thoroughly.
Tasha: 搅拌到完全融合
Tasha: Mix until fully combined.
Lucia: 新的碗
Jake:好来吧
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes
Jake:可能吗
Tasha: 真的可以
Tasha: It's really okay.
Tasha: 这是真的可以
Lucia: 至少肉眼上完全了
Lucia: At least it looks fully combined.
Jake:这是什么啊牛奶和油
Jake:这真的可以吗ok
Lucia: 就至少肉眼上可以
Lucia: At least it looks okay.
Tasha: 40克
Tasha: 完了这用的太快了
Tasha: 补个货
Jake:好补
Jake:怎么补
Tasha: 面粉哪都有
Jake:好
Tasha: 哇ok
Lucia: 嗯又灭了吗
Lucia: Hmm, did it go out again?
Lucia: 他们又灭了
Lucia: They went out again.
Tasha: 又灭了
Lucia: 咱今天晚上能吃上饭不
Lucia: Can we even get to eat dinner tonight?
Shure: 能哎呦
Shure: Got it, oh!
Lucia: 哎呦吓我一跳
Lucia: Oh, you scared me!
Tasha: 哎呦哈哈
Tasha: Oh, haha!
Lucia: 哈哈哈行
Lucia: Hahaha, okay.
Shure: 不要质疑我
Shure: Don't doubt me.
Lucia: 有您这句话我就放心了
Lucia: With your words, I'm relieved.
Tasha: 有您这句话我就放心了
Tasha: With your words, I'm relieved.
Shure: 咱保底不是还有外卖吗
Shure: We still have takeout as a backup.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 不行这些就拿
Shure: If it doesn't work, just take this...
Shure: 锅一炒
Shure: and stir-fry it in the pan.
Tasha: 为了防止你的问题
Tasha: 我已经做了第二种甜品了
Tasha: I've already made the second dessert.
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 剩下这些不行
Shure: If these don't work...
Lucia: backup plan
Lucia: Backup plan.
Katrina: 我要吃一块披萨
Katrina: I want to eat a slice of pizza.
Shure: 还可以炒
Shure: We can still stir-fry.
Alice:没有明火是不行的
Alice: It won't work without an open flame.
Tasha: 您OK了吧
Tasha: Are you okay now?
Tasha: OK了OK了
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Jake:还不行
Jake: It's still not working.
Tasha: 啊嗯
Tasha: Ah, hmm.
Lucia: 好了好了好了
Lucia: Alright, alright, alright.
Tasha: 来吧放在这里
Jake:放在哪里
Tasha: 这里
Tasha: 然后继续搅
Tasha: Then keep stirring.
Tasha: 对对不我说等会继续搅
Tasha: Yes, yes. No, I mean wait and then continue stirring.
Jake:这是面粉吗
Tasha: 是不是应该换个大点
Tasha: Should we switch to a bigger one?
Jake:这个是要做什么
Jake: What is this for?
Tasha: 这个这个就做第2种甜品
Tasha: This, this is for making the second dessert.
Tasha: 就纸杯蛋糕呀
Tasha: It's just a cupcake.
Tasha: 可以爆浆
Tasha: It can have a molten center.
Alice:笑死
Alice: So funny
Lucia: 听起来就好好吃哦
Lucia: Sounds delicious
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Jake:就这个纸杯吗
Jake: Just this paper cup?
Lucia: 对就咱们那天做的那种
Lucia: Yeah, like the ones we made that day
Tasha: 但是再升升升升级也可以
Tasha: But we can upgrade it more and more
Tasha: 好了
Lucia: 开始搅拌
Lucia: Start mixing
Tasha: 搅拌到看不到面粉就行
Tasha: Mix until you can't see the flour
Tasha: 甜点大师诞生了
Tasha: A dessert master is born
Tasha: 两位两位后厨人员配一位大师
Tasha: Two kitchen staff and one master
Lucia: 哈哈大师
Lucia: Haha master
Lucia: 等一下啊好吧
Lucia: Wait a second, okay
Lucia: 我怎么给他擦的和成面了都哈哈哈
Lucia: How did I clean it so much that it turned into dough, haha
Tasha: OK我们可以把蛋清那个啊
Tasha: OK, we can add the egg whites now
Tasha: 对对可以下一步
Tasha: Yes, yes, we can move to the next step
Katrina: 帅
Katrina: Cool
Katrina: 像魔术师一样
Katrina: Like a magician
Tasha: 哇哇有种大厨的感觉
Tasha: Wow, it feels like a top chef
Tasha: 你要来打发
Tasha: Are you going to whip it?
Tasha: 打发吗
Tasha: Whip it?
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Sure.
Tasha: 可以哎把那个头拿来就行对
Tasha: Sure, just bring that part over here.
Lucia: 呃安上是吧好嘞
Lucia: Uh, put it on, right? Got it.
Tasha: 啊哦
Tasha: Ah, oh.
Lucia: 哦我来帮你挤我来帮你挤
Lucia: Oh, let me help you squeeze it out.
Lucia: 哦你们在这
Lucia: 我刚没有看到
Tasha: 怎么办挤了一颗种子进去
Tasha: What should we do? I squeezed a seed in.
Tasha: 我直接用手拿他
Tasha: I'll just grab it with my hand.
Tasha: 他怎么这么不听话
Tasha: Why is it so disobedient?
Tasha: 我靠哈哈哈
Tasha: Oh man, hahaha.
Jake:我是不是搅多了啊
Tasha: 怎么个搅多法呢
Tasha: 不多来
Tasha: Not too much, come on.
Tasha: 放进来继续搅
Tasha: Put it in and keep stirring.
Lucia: 然后现在可以打了吗还是啥
Lucia: So, can we beat it now or what?
Tasha: 呃对打
Tasha: Uh, yes, beat it.
Lucia: 我是要把这个头先放进去
Lucia: Should I put this part in first?
Lucia: 然后把它调到
Lucia: And then set it to...
Tasha: 对对对对对对对对对对
Tasha: Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 直接调到五
Lucia: Just turn it to five.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 来吧继续抽
Tasha: Come on, keep drawing.
Tasha: 哎用这个抽就可以了啊
Tasha: Oh, you can use this to draw.
Tasha: 好吧你用这个抽也可以
Tasha: Okay, you can use this to draw too.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 呃可以
Tasha: Uh, okay.
Shure: 这时候现在知道谁知盘中餐
Shure: Now you know how hard it is to earn your food.
Shure: 粒粒皆辛苦了吧
Shure: Every grain is hard-earned.
Tasha: 好对
Tasha: Yes, right.
Tasha: 可以了然后然后加糖
Tasha: That's enough, then add sugar.
Tasha: 就是糖分三次加
Tasha: Add the sugar in three batches.
Tasha: 你看第一次就这种
Tasha: See, the first batch is like this.
Tasha: 有这种粗粗的气孔的时候加
Tasha: When you see these coarse bubbles, add it.
Tasha: 然后呢打到那种没有粗粗的气孔
Tasha: Then, beat it until there are no coarse bubbles.
Tasha: 打到绵密的气孔的时候加第二次
Tasha: Beat it until there are fine bubbles, then add the second batch.
Lucia: 绵密的气孔好的
Alice:看就差不多了
Alice: See, it's almost done.
Shure: 对其实差不多了
Shure: Yes, it's almost done.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 这样看起来还可以
Lucia: This looks alright.
Tasha: 这就是绵密气孔
Tasha: These are the fine bubbles.
Tasha: 然后再加第二
Tasha: Then add the second.
Tasha: 第二次烫可以多加一点
Tasha: The second batch of sugar can be more.
Tasha: 让他帮助他定型
Tasha: Let him help shape it.
Tasha: 然后还剩一点点就是最后成型
Tasha: Then there's just a little bit left to finalize it.
Lucia: 这个这次要打到大概什么样
Tasha: 呃打到
Tasha: Uh, fill it up to?
Tasha: 你看着打吧
Tasha: Just watch and fill.
Lucia: 啊哈哈就是
Lucia: Ahahaha, just...
Jake:看着打
Lucia: what
Lucia: What?
Tasha: 哇哈哈
Tasha: Wahaha.
Jake:哎呀怎么了
Tasha: 就是一个在搅一个在搅
Tasha: One's stirring, one's stirring.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 不要你喽
Katrina: She doesn't want you anymore.
Tasha: 差不多吧
Tasha: Almost there.
Katrina: 嗨
Katrina: Hi.
Tasha: 然后加最后一次
Tasha: Then add the last time.
Tasha: 最后一次就是要他提起来
Tasha: The last time is to lift it up.
Tasha: 就你看他就倒了
Tasha: You see, it's falling.
Tasha: 要提起来
Tasha: Lift it up.
Tasha: 不倒就行了嗯
Tasha: As long as it doesn't fall, it's fine, yeah.
Tasha: 好了你这边没什么问题了
Tasha: Okay, there's no problem on your side.
Jake:好的谢谢你谢谢夸奖
Katrina: 我就是戴了一个普通的眼镜而已
Katrina: I'm just wearing regular glasses.
Tasha: 然后等他哈哈哈
Tasha: Then wait for it, hahaha.
Jake:加油加油
Lucia: 嗯哈哈还可以助威吗
Lucia: Hmm, can we cheer too?
Jake:对
Lucia: 看一眼先好像还有一点
Lucia: It seems there's still a bit of eyeliner.
Lucia: 那个啥我眼镜往下滑了
Lucia: My glasses are slipping down.
Tasha: 稳定了吗
Tasha: Is it stable?
Lucia: 刚才好像还不太行
Lucia: It didn't seem to work earlier.
Lucia: 稍等现在再试一下
Lucia: Hold on, let me try again now.
Tasha: 差不多差不多嘛
Tasha: Pretty much, yeah.
Lucia: 还是这样搅
Lucia: Keep stirring like this.
Tasha: 嗯你加5克玉米淀粉进去
Tasha: Hmm, add 5 grams of cornstarch.
Tasha: 他就会成定的更快一点
Tasha: It'll set faster that way.
Tasha: 差不多可以了
Tasha: 嗯可以
Tasha: Hmm, it's fine.
Lucia: 嗯好的
Katrina: 我们今天又去
Katrina: Today we went to the
Katrina: 超市了
Katrina: supermarket again.
Tasha: 你你你这样子
Tasha: You, you, like this
Tasha: 你其实这样子
Tasha: Actually, if you do this
Tasha: 就是空白的地方
Tasha: in the blank space
Tasha: 他就转出来了
Tasha: It'll turn out.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 哦哈哈
Tasha: Oh haha.
Katrina: 我们不用干活
Katrina: We don't need to work.
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Katrina: 我们戴眼镜就算干活了呀
Katrina: We just wear glasses, and it's considered working?
Lucia: 取下来
Lucia: Take it off.
Katrina: 是我们每天的
Katrina: That's what we do every day.
Lucia: 然后这个就可以洗掉了是吧
Lucia: Then this can be washed off, right?
Katrina: 天午饭
Katrina: Lunch.
Tasha: 对洗掉
Tasha: Yes, wash it off.
Katrina: 去公园去买烤肉
Katrina: Go to the park to buy barbecue.
Tasha: 对他洗掉之后还有用
Tasha: Yes, after washing it off, it's still useful.
Lucia: 就是打发奶油要用
Lucia: We need it to whip the cream.
Tasha: 就是打发奶油要用
Tasha: Yes, it's needed to whip the cream.
Lucia: 哦好的
Lucia: Oh, got it.
Lucia: 所以橄榄油应该是一会才用吧
Lucia: So the olive oil should be used later, right?
Tasha: 嗯等蛋糕胚烤好再打
Tasha: Yes, wait until the cake base is baked.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Tasha: 嗯做两种蛋糕
Tasha: Yes, making two kinds of cakes.
Tasha: 因为感嗯太咸了
Tasha: Because it’s too salty.
Tasha: 感觉外面
Tasha: It feels like outside.
Katrina: 外面的火还没起来呢
Katrina: The fire outside hasn't started yet.
Tasha: 还没起来
Tasha: Hasn't started yet.
Katrina: 他那个炭烧不着
Katrina: The charcoal won't light up.